we are 23 seats short I want to be able  to say that without getting much is  wrong expect to create a thousand jobs  today that's two million new jobs for  two million people the only people the  toys have said they detect are then  friends big business and in big houses  this action phase wheels with an  unprecedented opportunity if my camry  horns the balance of power we will use  that to rebalance power and wealth  throughout the UK I would Jen correos  Owens had instead board a balanced plan  to get the deficit down in a fair way  thank you very much if you please have  some other state about the immigration  debate I policies very straight to you  we want to take back control our borders  yes ND have a substantial lead over  labor for six months what we need to do  is work hard then make your of a  powerful Scotland  over soon